a new study out of washington university
has found that a full
42
of women who have received covid
vaccines have experienced changes to
their menstrual cycle which is of course
impossible because the public health
authorities assured us that the vaccines
could not in any way
affect women's cycles
we're going to turn now to our dr jen
ashton who has some answers to some of
your more pressing medical questions
we'll start with the first one dr jen is
there a relationship between the
vaccines and menstrual cycles we've
definitely talked about we sure have you
guys and this is really spreading like
wildfire on social media with zero
scientific or medical basis for this
remember in medicine every time we talk
about a study of finding what is the
first thing we say big difference
between association
and causation so yes women can get the
vaccine and then experience changes in
their menstrual cycle that does not mean
that one causes the other and in fact if
you look at the biology of how these
vaccines work there is
zero hormonal interaction so please
let's put that to rest yes this got a
lot of attention because a school
actually in florida was telling teachers
yeah that they used sight at this as a
reason for not being vaccinated defy
science so
defies science so
let's
let's put that to rest because it defies
science not only did the vaccines not
affect menstruation according to the
public health establishment but it was
scientifically impossible for them to
affect menstruation social media
companies censored and de-platformed
people for suggesting that they did
and then something really weird happened
women started noticing that the vaccines
were in fact affecting their menstrual
cycles
and eventually enough women noticed that
phenomenon that it became undeniable so
the establishment
completely changed its tune loosened up
the language a little bit and starting
in january of this year they started to
admit
small changes here we go this is this is
from abc it's funny this is from the
same network as good morning america
that we were just watching covid19
vaccine linked to small
temporary changes in menstrual cycles
study fines so the very same outlet the
very same network the very same show
went from scientifically impossible defy
science to yeah okay
some small changes very small
very temporary nothing to see here move
along move along
now of course they're admitting
to slightly larger changes the
researchers behind the washington
university study observed that many of
the study participants experienced
changes to their cycles lasting more
than a week after vaccination which is
important because that is beyond the
period in which adverse symptom
reporting is closely monitored during
vaccine trials how much longer than a
week we just don't know
now the medical establishment insists
okay fine
the menstrual changes do occur but they
won't have any long-term consequences
and of course the public health gurus
don't have any proof to back up this
claim because the vaccines have only
existed for a year and a half and there
are no long-term data period they just
don't exist so now you've got a choice
to make
you can either believe the fancy
credentialed genius powerful public
health officials in the white lab coats
you know the people who told you that
the vaccines would prevent infection and
would prevent transmission and could not
possibly affect women's menstrual cycles
and on and on in other words the people
who've gotten pretty much everything
about covid wrong from the start or
you can believe the knuckle dragging
conspiracy theorists deplorables who
urged caution from the beginning and
though they don't generally possess
fancy medical degrees or positions of
public authority
have pretty much gotten everything right
that's your choice i'm michael knowles
this the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment friday is from debt slim jim 12.
what a name who says
speaking of child abuse the cdc
is definitely a top-tier michael knowles
transition yes thank you i appreciate
that
i'm sorry that that is a top tier
transition but that's what we've come to
expect because nobody has any respect
whatsoever anymore
for the cdc and the rest of the public
health authorities
it's very difficult it makes us anxious
to think about these people lying to us
so when i want to try to get some sleep
at night you know what i need i need my
helix mattress right now go to
helixsleep.com i have had my helix
mattress for a little under a year and a
half and i absolutely love it i adore it
one it's super easy to unbox they bring
it right to your house boom boom boom it
opens up super easy you sleep like never
before it's just so wonderful tailored
exactly to your sleep preferences the
way they do that
they've got a quiz that takes two
minutes to complete matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you with helix
you're getting a mattress that you know
will be perfect for the way that you
sleep everyone's unique helix knows that
they have several different mattress
models to choose from soft medium and
firm mattresses mattress is great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
mattress is great for spinal alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains i
just love it
absolutely cannot recommend these guys
enough you do not need to go to the
mattress store ever again go to
helixsleep.com knowles take their two
minutes sleep quiz they will match you
to a customized mattress give you the
best sleep of your life they've got a 10
year warranty you can try it out for 100
nights risk-free they'll even pick it up
if you don't love it but you will love
it for a limited time get up to 350 off
all mattress orders plus two free
pillows for our listeners it's their
best offer yet hurry over to
helixsleep.com
knowles
i have such little respect at this point
for the public health establishment that
if i were sick or a family member were
sick and i were given two choices of
doctors let's say that the choices
between
dr harvard yale princeton
dr harvard yelp princeton with his
stethoscope and his white lab coat and
dr alex jones who is standing naked
eating vitamin supplements with a
tinfoil hat on and those are my two
choices it's not even a question
it's not even a question
i go to dr jones
ten times out of ten
because
legitimately if you're if you're
comparing someone like alex jones i mean
i use him because he's the most uh clear
example of this someone derided as a
crazy and a kook and deplatformed and
everything for raising questions about
what the establishment is saying with
regard to covid and all the rest of it
you know you look at that guy and then
you look at dr fauci
fauci has a way worse record okay it's
all of them it's the whole public health
establishment why why do you think
people might be losing some faith in the
public health establishment
one picture tells you the whole story
this is a picture from
over the weekend
this is a picture of dr richard levine
who calls himself rachel and sam brinton
these are two dudes showing up to a
party at the french ambassador's
residence
richard levine is the
secretary assistant secretary of health
sam brinton is in charge of nuclear
materials
at the department of energy
and both of these men showed up wearing
dresses
and
women's shoes
and then they took a photo together
sam brinton posts week four on the job
champagne
and celebration with the french
ambassador in his residence for bastille
day
also amazing opportunity to connect with
one of the only other transgender
government officials
admiral levine not gonna lie it felt
great to commiserate
with a fellow trans person facing the
hate
i don't know that they get hate i don't
think that levine and brenton get hate
they do get criticism legitimate
criticism which is hey you're men you
shouldn't dress up like women hey you're
men you shouldn't pretend to be women
hey
uh admiral levine
dr levine um you shouldn't be promoting
the use of puberty blockers and
cross-sex hormones and mutilation
surgeries for tiny little kids that's
very abusive and wrong that's critic
it's criticism it's not hate though it's
legitimate criticism
because they're doing bad things and
they're doing wrong things and in the
case of sam brenton he has
not just committed private sexual sins
that got out he has made a big show of
his sexual degeneracy he's apparently a
puppy fetishist which i apparently is
different than bestiality but it's where
he and his
homosexual lover dress up like dogs and
then do all sorts of strange things and
leather and whatever whatever it is it's
not like this is some private sin and
scandal that was uncovered he he gives
lectures about this he goes around and
parades these kinds of behaviors in
public and the consequence of that is
that these guys are a national
embarrassment it is embarrassing these
guys are representing the united states
they are they are a public face of our
country and they're doing things that
are shameful and embarrassing and i
don't even
mean to wag my finger and blame them and
try to humiliate them or anything like
that
or expose some private sins they're
doing this publicly they're the ones
humiliating us
okay it's not that it's not the
conservatives who are being graceless
and cruel here and harsh and and
mean-spirited
we would we would be more than happy to
live and let live and whatever you know
if you're if they want to do weird puppy
stuff in the bedroom and don't tell
anybody about it i guess that's not our
business we're not going to find out
about it but when you parade all of this
stuff in public
and then when you take it even further
like richard levine does and says that
my own disorders and perversions i'm now
going to foist on little kids and
advocate transiting the kids well that's
a big problem that's a national
embarrassment it's a national scandal
and we don't want it and i know that
there i think probably the vast majority
of america feels this way when they see
this as the public face of america they
feel humiliated and ashamed you know the
rest of the world is laughing at us but
a lot of people don't feel that they
ought to express that that legitimate
sentiment because they feel that it's
phobic or mean or something it's not
it's not there's nothing phobic about
that we're talking about politics we're
talking about public life okay and these
people in public life are an
embarrassment and it's there's nothing
wrong with people
not wanting to be embarrassed at the
national level okay there's there's
absolutely nothing wrong or phobic or
irrational with saying hey fellas you're
clearly going through something right
now and so you need to go deal with your
own problems and then if you want to
come back into public life maybe you can
but you've got to make a choice you can
either engage in very degrading actions
that are humiliating and for whatever
reason they get your rocks off or
you can suppress those degrading and
debasing behaviors and be a public face
for the united states but you can't do
both
you've got to ch
we as americans have a right to some
national honor we have a right to some
national dignity we have a right to some
integrity from our public health
officials
and if we're not going to get that the
criticism is totally legitimate it's not
hate it's not mean i don't think any any
one of us wishes these people ill or
harbor some deep-seated hatred for them
we just want our public officials
to make us proud to make us stand a
little straighter to look at them and
say yes i'm glad those guys are
representing us and it's not just sam
brinton and it's not just richard levine
the problem of national embarrassments
representing us goes all the way up to
the top
and the guy at the top one of the big
problems with him is that he's extremely
old and
when you get old you get close to
shaking off this mortal coil and when
you do that you want to make sure you
have a will that's why you got to go
check out epic will right now head on
over to epicwill.com use code knowles
because you will die
i have news for you my friend you will
die do you go skydiving you will die do
you breathe oxygen you will die no one
here gets out alive not in this world my
friends
so you need to have a will okay a will
is not about you it's about your loved
ones it's about the really difficult
decisions they will face if something
happens to you excuse me when something
happens to you do yourself a favor do
your family a favor make those decisions
now so that they don't have to face them
later without you
epic will makes it so so easy to get
your affairs in order i just finished up
my will about a month or so ago epic
will is taking care of a ton of people
here at the daily wire go to
epicwell.com use promo code knowles
k-w-l-e-s save 10
on epic will's complete package right
now you can get a will in as little as
five minutes super duper easy well worth
119 bucks to secure your family's future
without a will you might as well wrap up
all your money and your assets and your
kids hand them over to the state do not
do that you probably don't want that to
happen right now go to
epicwill.com use code nulls take you
five minutes square away the rest of
your life and you can move on epic
will.com
code
knowles you want to talk about a
national embarrassment
joe biden
joe biden is making his beg for oil tour
around the middle east
and biden really irked a lot of people
not just on the right but especially on
the left over at the end of last week
because he shows up to saudi arabia and
basically just begs the crown prince for
oil
the reason for this is that joe biden
shut down new oil and gas production in
the united states and shut down new oil
pipelines even though he gave the green
light to an oil pipeline for vladimir
putin he's giving the green light he's
actually begging the middle eastern oil
states to produce more oil but he's just
not producing american oil i guess saudi
arabian oil doesn't pollute the
environment in the way that american oil
does
it doesn't make sense to me but that
must be the premise here i don't know
why it's okay for saudi arabia to
produce oil and profit from that but
it's not okay for americans to do the
very same so he's going around he's
begging people to get more oil and the
thing that really irked the left was he
goes to saudi arabia and he gives a fist
bump to the saudi crown prince
mohammed bin salman
now
this is embarrassing i want again it
gets to this issue of national dignity i
want my leaders to not behave like
teenagers you know i'd been nice
handshake would be good sturdy handshake
but okay he gives the fist bump fine
whatever the reason the lives are upset
by the fist bump is that for the past
three four years or longer they have
been painting muhammad bin salman as the
worst
terrible murderous monster barbarian in
the entire world and the reason they've
done that
or the reason that they've been able to
make this argument is because the head
of saudi arabia muhammad bin salman
killed assassinated
the
that disinterested symbol of journalism
jamal khashoggi
do you remember jamal khashoggi
jamal maybe you don't remember it i mean
the news cycles move so fast now jamal
khashoggi here's here is the story that
was presented by jamal khashoggi he was
a a journalist a reporter a columnist
for the washington post who was just
minding his own business in turkey and
the saudi crown prince sent his thugs
his assassins to
the to the residents where jamal
khashoggi was staying and they chopped
him up and they tortured him and they
killed him
because he was speaking truth to power
and he was a disinterested journalist
and this was an attack on the fourth
estate and the free press everywhere
and that's not what happened that's not
what happened at all
the jamal khashoggi story was just
complete propaganda jamal khashoggi was
a political operative and a spy he was
not in any
reasonable use of the term a journalist
jamal khashoggi had been a spy for saudi
arabia he had been a spy for saudi
arabia's enemies he had palled around
and worked with osama bin laden back in
the early days of al-qaeda he was on the
payroll of qatar he would have these
foreign interests draft sometimes write
whole portions of the columns that he
would submit to the washington post and
other publications he was an influence
peddler he was a political operative he
had been on the good side of parts of
the saudi royal family then he fell on
the bad bad side of parts of the soil
saudi royal family and he was working
for some of the saudi enemies so the
saudis did what the saudis do
what a lot of states do and they went
out and assassinated their enemies i'm
not i'm not defending the assassination
of the enemies of saudi arabia
but i am saying this is kind of par for
the course
and it's very different than the story
that had been presented which is that
saudi arabia was attacking the free
press that's not it at all what you saw
playing out there
with the assassination of jamal
khashoggi and really the subsequent
media spin around it is
you saw two competing interests
especially in the united states
the libs went crazy over the killing of
jamal khashoggi because the libs hate
saudi arabia they want us to back away
from saudi arabia in our relationship
there and they want us to cozy up to
iran
the conservatives tend to think that
we're better with the devil we know than
the devil we don't and they prefer that
we remain allies with saudi arabia and
that we don't cozy up to iran and we
don't give iran pallets of cash and we
don't give iran a nuclear weapon
and so and there are a lot of other
regional powers at play there as well so
the libs pounced on the jamal khashoggi
killing to try to generate
worldwide opposition to saudi arabia and
to get people to cozy up more to iran
it was just
it was just a
propaganda operation to shift certain
geopolitical alliances and the reason i
mentioned it is because a lot of people
fell for it the washington post is still
going crazy over the killing of jamal
khashoggi as some attack on the press
and a lot of people fell for it because
they violate the first rule when you are
reading any news story talked about this
a couple weeks ago but it's really
important to to keep in mind
when you are reading a news report about
any story domestic
foreign economic crime immigration
whatever the first question you have to
ask yourself before you even get to the
the facts the who what where when why
you have to ask you have to ask a why
question about the story itself you have
to ask what is the angle
when you read the new york times when
you're reading the daily wire when
you're reading anything in between you
need to ask yourself okay what is the
angle here why is this story
being reported
now by this news outlet
why
journalism costs money
people are putting their resources in a
certain place so people are going to
make decisions on how to deploy those
resources there are always political
considerations that come into that so
you've got to ask yourself and it's just
particular it's true across the
political spectrum but it's particularly
egregious when we're talking about the
washington post or the new york times
where there are huge entrenched corrupt
interests that fund these papers
what is the angle why is this being
reported now
why am i being told that the the
assassination of an ex-saudi spy
is
the worst attack on a free press in the
history of the world and you realize it
actually has nothing to do with jamal
khashoggi has nothing to do with the
press it has nothing to do with
washington post it has everything to do
with giant political forces trying to
restructure the world order
speaking of death there's a there's a
new blm idol that's out there you might
you might have missed this one if you
were at having a barbecue with your
family this weekend you might have
missed that a new blm idol dropped this
person is techley sundberg
tecla sundberg
was a young man who
according to investigators fired
multiple gunshots inside a seward
neighborhood
in minneapolis
uh and inside this apartment building on
wednesday night
and so the police were called they were
trying to talk this guy down they were
trying to get the guy to surrender the
guy just would not surrender and
eventually the cops killed him
and now there are blm demonstrations
people showing up justice for tecla he
was killed by the racist minneapolis
cops because he's a black man and they
were making their demonstrations
which were interrupted by a really
inconvenient person for the blm crowd
the inconvenient person would be the
victim who was almost murdered with her
two little kids
by tecla sundberg
[Music]
i'm sure it was a
terrible you're alive
[Music]
you're
alive is not okay you're alive the
bullet missed you so stop complaining
you have to deal with this and probably
have a mental illness now because they
almost lost of course the kids are
dramatic
in my kitchen
[Music]
she's obviously going through a moment
this is not okay
shut up
shut up
imagine you're a mother
and you say i mean you really you've
totally feel for this one she's saying
this guy
tried to kill me
and my children
but me in front of my kids or my
children in front of me or all of us at
once
and you are all
crying because this guy
was taken out by police before he could
successfully kill me and my children
and now you're really upset that he
wasn't allowed to keep shooting do you
do you see how that's kind of offensive
to me
and blm doesn't care you heard the
the protesters out there say shut up
you're fine there's bullet holes in my
wall yeah there's not bullet holes in
you shut up it's not about you it's
about our narrative our and our
according to our narrative this guy who
was shooting you through your walls and
almost killed your kids he was a poor
innocent victim he was probably unarmed
i don't know where those bullets came
from and you need to shut up and stop
contradicting our narrative or else
if you ever thought to yourself
i bet working at the daily wire is a
fantastic experience you're insane what
are you talking about now i'm joking
you're in luck we are growing we are
hiring legitimately i walk around this
place i've always prided myself on being
pals with most people around the daily
wire you know i've been here since
pretty much the very beginning of the
company we're hiring so many people i
look every two hours they say when did
you get here oh you got your 20 minutes
ago okay all right nice to meet you you
might be the next person to join us we
are expanding our in-house ad sales team
there are several new open positions
including digital sales representative
senior ad operations manager and client
success manager prior experience in
digital and audio sales is a must
this is an incredible opportunity
to be a key player in the daily wire
business these positions are based here
in nashville
for more details and to apply visit
dailywire.com careers we'll be right
back with a lot more
what's most interesting about the tecla
sunburg story which is he's the new
newest blm idol in minneapolis which is
epicenter for blm
what's most interesting is not the
divergence between reality and
and the blm narrative blm narrative he
was poor man this poor innocent man the
cops shouldn't have shot him the the
reality is he was shooting at his
neighbors almost killed a woman and her
two kids the cops came in and put him
down like old yeller and they even gave
him a long time to surrender but he had
to be put down he was put down the cops
did the right thing okay easy enough
the what's most interesting to me is not
that blm lies blm always lies what's
interesting to me is when that woman who
was almost killed with her kids by tecla
sunberg when she was justifying
her anger at the demonstrators when she
was trying to persuade them not to
protest the cops
for saving her life and her kids lives
she she had to justify it on racial
lines
she kept saying this is not a george
floyd's situation
as though the cops were completely had
no right to interfere in in george floyd
george floyd totally innocent victim
right she's it seems to be implicitly
buying into the blm narrative on george
floyd and then she says my kids were
almost killed my kids were traumatized
my kids are in the car and that's not
working she says my black kids
they're not like those evil white kids
they're not like those terrible white
kids if they got shot that'd be fine or
if the white kids were traumatized who
care we hate those white kids they're
black kids and because they're black
kids surely then you have to have some
sympathy with me and it's really it's
really sad
and ugly
that that's the place we're at but it
does
seem to buttress something that we've
talked about on this show for a long
time which is that the
civil rights racial narrative is the
narrative in american politics
everything has to fit into that
narrative one of the primary arguments
in the pro-life movement in the
anti-abortion movement has been that
abortion
one was begun as a political program in
america largely to target blacks and
that it disproportionately kills blacks
and it's racist they make abortion about
race so many of the economic arguments
we make about taxes about economic
growth we make on racial lines this
disproportionately hurts black people
this disproportionately is racist
so many of the arguments we make about
education come down to race so many of
the arguments we make about immigration
come down to race this is mass migration
reduces wages for people at the lower
end of the income spectrum which
disproportionately affects racial
minorities so
almost all of the arguments come down to
that
this this
uh has been building for a long time in
american politics but even here you just
see it at its most absurd extreme a
woman
who is
justifying anger that her kids were
almost killed by guns by this by this
maniac just popping off bullets through
the wall and then the cops take him out
she's she's trying to justify why she
thinks the killing of the shooter was
okay and she she has to justify even
that on racial lines so my kids are
black
they're not white
come on you'd have a point if they were
white but they're black
really really bizarre and really really
sad and and you see it not even just in
america this racial political narrative
as the as the dominant thread
in western politics it's true in britain
too on a completely different sort of
story but the same theme here
a british dance school
has just dropped ballet from its
audition process
and it's dropped ballet from the
audition process because it's quote
built around white european ideas
britain
historically one of the whitest
countries ever is not allowed to have
ballet
at its dance school
because ballet is too white
one uh non-white people can dance ballet
last i checked but two why are
why are why are white dances terrible
why are we not allowed to have white
dances britain's north northern school
of contemporary dance dropped ballet
from that process because not only is it
too white
and european but it's too gendered as
well and this is being reported by the
telegraph it's got a potentially
contentious nature here is what
the head of undergraduate studies at the
dance school says it is essentially an
elitist form young people need to pay to
take ballet classes as a general rule
and for a vast number of potential
students they've not had access to
ballet and so we've got to get rid of
ballet when we're considering who should
come into the dance school
and she's saying it's elitist you have
to pay you have to train it requires a
lot of skill and so we've got to get rid
of that
one the argument is kind of racist right
they're saying oh this thing that
requires a lot of skill and time and
effort and it's really beautiful and
intricate and sophisticated yeah that's
just for white people
that's just for white view all the
non-white people they can just kind of
stomp around without any skill
whatsoever that's fine for them but we
you know listen here we we
we're so progressive we're so woke that
we're going to get rid of all of the
sophisticated beautiful dancers because
those are clearly just for white people
the black people could never dance
ballet that's crazy crazy talk don't you
think so there is a kind of irony here
that they are embodying the very thing
that they're pretending to attack but
two
i like ballet i like nice things i like
things that require skill i like things
that require training i don't think that
only white people can do things that
require skill and training and that are
beautiful
why is it
that in the name of racial equity
we have to bring everything down
why can't we bring everyone up i have
faith that we can bring people up
regardless of their race i have faith
that we can
train people and teach and teach people
to look for the good the true and the
beautiful and do all the sorts of i i
have faith that that can happen i think
i think there's quite quite a lot of
evidence that that has happened in the
past
what here though is they say nope sorry
because of racism you don't
because of racial politics you no longer
get ballet i think this really doesn't
play for the libs who are pushing it i
in the long run it's been an effective
strategy for them
but
when people see it too clearly when when
in the short run when they go a little
too far a little too fast there's a huge
amount of backlash
when you're getting this right now you
can see you don't have to take my word
for it you're seeing it in the public
opinion polls and you're not just a
public opinion false but public opinion
polls from the libs one of the national
teachers unions
just did a battleground state survey
asking what people thought about ron
desantis education policy positions and
specifically on critical race theory
racial lessons in schools and they
realize this stuff is a total loser
by a 32 percentage point margin the poll
said a voters rather in the poll said
that they were more likely to vote for
candidates who believe public schools
should focus less on teaching race
and more on core subjects 32 points
that's a poll
pushed by the libs by 27 points voters
said schools should be banned from
teaching sexual orientation and gender
identity to kids in kindergarten through
third grade which like duh of course
it's pathetic that we even need to frame
the question that way fourth graders
let's you know teach them about ball
gags and puppy play with sam brinton and
the rest of the weirdos in our national
sexual uh revolution
but no no but third grade that's a
little too young and then by 28
percentage points they say that
transgender athletes should be banned
from competing in girls sports
this is an obvious loser
for
the libs
and it's why desantis is being talked
about as
a major republican presidential
candidate for 2024 if not
very nearly the presumptive nominee
trump really throws a wrench into all of
those plans but desantis is being talked
about
in at the presidential level in a way
that i have rarely seen candidates
talked about and it's because he's just
doubling down on this message he did it
again earlier this month
you can't put a price tag on opportunity
for kids and making sure parents uh have
the ability and of course separate from
the budget you know we believe that when
parents send their kids to school it's
for education not for indoctrination and
we're going to hold that line in florida
now this line literally
is is not the most meaningful line in
the world when people say this it's for
education not for indoctrination
they're really saying we support my kind
of education not their kind of education
education and indoctrination mean
essentially the same thing it's just
that one has a positive connotation and
one has a negative connotation it's a
little more complex than that because
education involves uh freeing people up
making them more human teaching them to
make sense of their freedom and their
rational will whereas indoctrination is
considered less thoughtful
and you know more akin to brainwashing
but
broadly speaking what we're really
talking about is the substance here you
know we think kids should be taught good
and true things and they shouldn't be
taught critical race theory and weird
sex stuff and puppy play and
transgenderism that's that's what we're
really saying but i get why ron desantis
is using the line i think it's a very
effective line it is true that slogans
are always wrong and shallow and they
can never get to the entirety of of a
political view
but
you know when you're in politics you've
got to use slogans that's politics is
made of slogans and ron desantis has hit
on a good one and when you look at what
that means in practice for ron desantis
he's done an excellent job on the issue
and the libs are losing on that issue
speaking of
the sexual revolution
my friend my favorite taco senator ted
cruz got in big trouble over the weekend
and it was actually on my show with
senator cruz verdict but it was on a
little bonus content you know we have
our friend liz wheeler come in and do
some bonus content for the
super duper inner circle
subscribe to the verdict plus community
type crowd and so they did they did a
bonus video and liz asked senator cruz
about the obergefell decision which
redefined marriage and senator cruz made
what i thought was a perfectly ordinary
unsurprising observation about that and
the libs lost their minds
in obergefell the court said no we know
better than you guys do and now every
state must
uh
must sanction and and permit gay
marriage
i think that decision was clearly wrong
when it was decided
um
it was the court overreaching
of course this is obviously true he's
saying that
uh the the court's decision in
obergefell was wrong
and the libs
lose it they start they start tweeting
about it they start big headlines
everywhere oh my gosh ted cruz opposes
the obergefell decision
of course of course that is the
conservative position
conservative believes that
the thing that everyone believed until
seven years ago is still true
and doesn't believe the wild radical
redefinition and innovation that took
place seven years ago because anthony
kennedy wanted to write romantic poetry
on the supreme court
oh my gosh shocking can you believe that
the libs really have no idea what we
believe
of course obergefell was wrongly decided
of course there is no constitutional
right to gay marriage
let's say you support redefining
marriage let's say you support old and
you're even happy about the court
decision
do you really believe
that
gay marriage was hiding out in the
constitution
through the end of the 19th century i'm
sorry through the end of the 18th
century through the entirety of the 19th
century through the entirety of the 20th
century and then only 15 years into the
21st century did we realize that it was
there all along we you really believe
that there was a definition of marriage
in the constitution that no one had
seriously considered until like five
minutes ago that that just happened to
be there all the time no nobody believes
that nobody believes that james madison
put gay marriage into the constitution
and it just laid dormant for 200 years
250 years no nobody believes that
what about the other decisions if you
guys are shocked if you libs are shocked
by what conservatives believe about a
vergafel just wait until you hear about
what we think about other supreme court
cases other supreme court cases like
lawrence v texas in 2003 finds a
constitutional right to homosexual
sodomy you might like homosexual sodomy
you might think it's a perfectly fine
thing to do you might think that we
ought to have a legal right to it do you
really believe
that that right is in the constitution
where show me the right to homosexual
sodomy in the constitution
you're not going to find it
and conservatives and honest liberals
were were united in that opinion until
at the very least 2003
really much later than that go back a
little further
the griswold and eisenstadt cases those
were the cases that found a
constitutional right to condoms in the
constitution
griswold was 1965 found a constitutional
right to condoms but only for married
couples in the constitution and then
seven years later 1972 you have the
eisenstadt case which found a
constitutional right to condoms for
everybody
including unmarried couples
maybe you like condoms
maybe you think condoms are perfectly
fine maybe you don't even like them for
sex you just like to use them to blow up
and make balloon animals i don't know
whatever you think do you do you
seriously believe
that condoms are in the constitution
somewhere especially when you're talking
about griswold where it was only condoms
for married couples
can you please point to me to the claws
of the constitution which is the condoms
but only for married couples claws of
the constitution where is that
just show me that text wherever you can
find that and then explain to me how the
supreme court took them seven years but
then they discovered no it's actually
not just there's condoms for everybody
not just for married couples where is
that clause
in the constitution
not everything that people want is in
the constitution not everything that
even p some people think is right is in
the constitution
no of course not of course there's no
right to that and some people i'm so
pleased to see that senator cruz said
this because it was it's just so
obviously true of course conservatives
should oppose the obergefell decision i
have i have liberal friends who oppose
the obergefell decision i have gay
friends who oppose the obergefell
decision i have gay friends
who get gay married who who nevertheless
because they're honest
believe that the obergefell decision was
ridiculous because of course it was
ridiculous and some people
the one that drives me the craziest is
some people try to to get out of the
question entirely and you know what they
say they say well listen when it comes
to marriage i just think government
should get out of the marriage business
entirely and they say this as though
this is some noble or clever third way
on the issue it's not
it's not
government
quote unquote government has always and
everywhere
regulated marriage in every single
society ever
and the reason for that is that marriage
is the fundamental political institution
it's it's not just a private institution
it's not just one person it's multiple
people and it's the bedrock of all
political society which is why all
governments all political communities
have had something to say about marriage
inevitably when you hear people say well
listen i don't
please stop asking my opinion on gay
marriage i just want to get marriage out
of get government out of the marriage
business entirely that is not some noble
or clever third way that is a surrender
that is a surrender of the institution
to the people
and the radicals who want to redefine
that institution that's all that it is
you have to stand up
for something you have to have some
vision of marriage the government is
going to say something about it the only
question that matters is not will the
government say something about it it
inevitably will the only question that
matters is
what is marriage
what is it that's all that was always
the question it wasn't do we hate gay
people should people have the right to
get married no
i believe that everyone has always had
the right to get married
because marriage necessarily involves
someone from the opposite sex
that's so the the question that you have
to ask is now do you have the right to
admire the question you have to ask is
what is marriage that's going to be the
next daily wire hit film i got to go i
got to go walk into jeremy's office
today and pitch that
because it's an important movie we
already did what is a woman now i guess
we have to do what is marriage
that's the that's the debate that should
have been had that's the debate that
should be had right now i think it's so
great
that senator cruz made this
totally common sense i haven't even
talked to him about this yet
i do don't tell him i'm complimenting
him please i don't you know listen i
don't want to get make a habit out of
this but
this was an amazing this was a really
really
important thing and watch the squishes
now
the people who run away from this point
to me they are not worth their salt as
conservatives or republicans someone
asked by the way on this issue okay so
even if people like condoms and even if
people like gay stuff and even if people
like some legal recognition of gay
unions or whatever even if we can grant
that none of that stuff is in the
constitution all those cases were
wrongly decided what about loving versus
virginia loving v virginia is the case
that uh
uh creates a constitution or recognizes
a constitutional right to interracial
marriage why isn't that one going to
disappear too and in the dobbs decision
clarence thomas who is himself in an
interracial marriage said we need to
revisit griswold we need to revisit
eisenstein we need to revisit obergefell
but he left out loving v virginia
so someone wrote into me and said i'm in
an interracial marriage why is
this line of thinking not going to
threaten my marriage it's because
loving v virginia is based on different
constitutional principles than those
other cases
all of those other cases rely on what's
called substantive due process which is
a contradiction in terms due process is
a process it's a procedure
you know you go you commit a crime then
you're brought up and you have you have
your right to due process in the justice
system
substantive due process is this idea
that you can you have certain rights to
process that don't involve a process and
it's just a bunch of legal gobbledygook
made-up legal gobbledygook that was
mentioned a little bit in the early 20th
century and really really exploded in
the middle to late 20th century when our
legal system went kind of kooky with all
of these cases and they said well you
certain rights that you can't see
anywhere and you can't find them in the
constitution you've got them they're in
between the emanations and the penumbras
and those rights are going to include
condoms and weird sex stuff and abortion
and all the rest of it substantive due
process is very silly and clarence
thomas made fun of it in his dobbs
concurrence
loving v virginia
is one
uh is is based on the equal protection
clause it doesn't it doesn't hinge on
substantive due process it hinges
largely on the equal protection clause
and also it observes just as in
historical matter that prohibitions
against interracial marriage against
miscegenation come out of the
institution of slavery and you can see
this in the law you can see this in the
earliest arguments and statutes
prohibiting interracial marriage so they
come out of this issue of slavery
slavery is abolished the uh that makes a
very good historical case to abolish
those kinds of arguments for
anti-miscegenation laws as well
they're not the same you're going to see
the the libs try as as
as conservatives become more aggressive
keep pushing the envelope a little bit
further now you're going to see the libs
try to make this about race because as
we mentioned earlier race is the
dominant theme in western politics not
even just american politics but western
politics entirely don't fall for it it's
just it's just completely made up and
the libs are making really really bad
arguments
are you seeing this too before we go
there's this last last story jennifer
gray
who was this actress from the 80s she
wrote in the la times she gave them an
interview and she she was lamenting the
dobbs decision the overruling of roe v
wade she said it doesn't feel real
she says i wouldn't have my life
i wouldn't have had the career i had i
wouldn't have had anything if she and
she acknowledges she had an abortion had
she not had the abortion she says i
wouldn't have anything wouldn't have my
career
wouldn't have all of it
to which i would ask what career
what career jennifer gray a lot of
people listening to the show probably
have no idea who jennifer gray is
jennifer gray was in
three movies
three popular movies
one of which was dirty dancing which
people don't even really watch anymore
and the main line from dirty dancing is
nobody puts baby in a corner how ironic
that she says in order to to have the
dirty dancing movie i had to kill my
baby nobody puts baby in a corner except
for me i do a lot worse than that she
was in ferris bueller she was in red
dawn that's kind of it
was it worth it it was worth killing
your kid even and jennifer gray would
say i've had a great amazing hollywood
career i'm famous i'm rich and all this
then she got a nose job and no one ever
heard from her again but she she says
you know i got everything for this
abortion they say was it worth it to be
in
three notable movies 35 years ago and
then to be completely forgotten that was
worth killing your kid i don't think so
that seems like some pretty medical
misinformation to me we got at the top
of the show we were talking about all
the lies that you've heard from the
medical establishment well how about
this one the lie that a baby's not a
baby
a
political medical establishment don't
forget public health is necessarily
political
that's what the word public means public
and political mean the same thing
a public health establishment that tells
you boys are actually girls and they got
everything about this pandemic wrong and
that tells you even more basically that
a human being a little baby is not a
baby that is not a public health
establishment that is ever going to
inspire trust i'm michael knowles it's
the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
today on the ben shapiro show after
promising that their expertise would
guide americans through economic
hardship foreign policy casts and global
pandemics the experts have destroyed
their own credibility but they still
insist you mimic their values that's
today on the bench bureau show give it a
listen